in previous videos we have talked about
how christianity evolved and developed
under the roman empire in particular we
saw that as we entered into the 4th
century that christianity continued to
be persecuted in particular by the
emperor diocletian who had some of the
worst persecutions of the christians but
over the course of the next century from
roughly 300 to 400 the relationship
between the roman empire and
christianity goes completely in the
opposite direction
as constantine takes over he becomes
sympathetic to the christians and he
eventually becomes christian himself
even then there was a lot of diversity
within the christian church there were
debates about the nature of jesus christ
relative to the father relative to the
holy spirit there were multiple sects of
christianity and one in particular
started to create a debate there was a
priest in alexandria which is one of the
major cities of the roman empire now
remember by this point rome of course is
the mo one of the most significant if
not the most significant
city now constantine sets up a capital
at byzantium which will eventually be
known as constantinople and alexandria
which was originally founded by
alexander the great is also one of the
significant cities of the empire and in
alexandria there is a christian priest
by the name of arius who has a view on
christ that becomes a bit of a
controversy and to understand that here
is an account of his writings or his
beliefs so this is arius of alexandria
if the father begat the son
he that was begotten had a beginning of
existence and from this it is evident
that there was a time when the sun was
not
it therefore necessarily follows that he
the son
had his substance from nothing
so he's drawing a distinction between
the essence of the father and the son
manifested as jesus christ now this is
very controversial because even his own
bishop in alexandria viewed the father
and the son to be of the same substance
now today you might say hey isn't this
just word play
it feels like it's semantic which is
really debating around the meaning of
words but
at the end of the roman empire and as we
get into the middle ages this was a
major issue of philosophical and it
would sometimes blend bleed over into
political debate
and so constantine who we mentioned has
a
sympathy towards the christians he
allows christianity to be tolerated he
does not like this idea of this debate
and he wants to help unify the
christians so in 325
he calls the council of nicaea to help
resolve
this controversy controversy which gets
known as the aryan controversy named
after aries of alexandria now it's worth
mentioning arius wasn't the first person
to make this argument that the father in
some way was more divine than the sun
because he begat the sun he existed
before the sun
but this controversy really revolves
around aries because he was especially
persuasive about spreading this view of
the relationship between the father and
the son manifested by jesus
and at the council of nicaea
many of the bishops throughout
christendom are in attendance it's known
as the first ecumenical conference the
word ecumenical comes from the greek
word for the inhabited earth so you can
view it as the church leaders from the
inhabited earth in order to create a
consensus about what it means to be a
christian
and arius of alexandria was there to
defend his position but the majority of
those there did not like his point of
view so they declared aries beliefs as
heresy and they exile him and to be very
clear that they do not believe that the
son is of a different substance of the
father they issue the nicene creed
so what i have here this is known as the
nicene constantinopolitan
creed and this is based on the nicene
creed which was established in 325 which
was shorter but then in 381 under
theodosius you have your second
ecumenical council which is held in
constantinople to reaffirm some of the
ideas of the nicene council and so as i
read this keep a look out for some of
these words which were really put there
to try to settle the
aryan controversy to try to ensure that
that type of belief does not surface
again we believe in one god the father
almighty maker of heaven and earth and
of all things visible and invisible
and in one lord jesus christ the son of
god the only begotten begotten of the
father before all ages so not like arius
was arguing that there was a time where
the father existed before the son
existed here it says begotten of the
father but but but before all ages so
there was always a time when there was a
sun
light of light very god of very god
begotten not made
of one essence with the father by whom
all things were made so once again
really addressing this aryan controversy
the aryan heresy as it becomes known
that the father and the son are of the
same essence one is not more divine than
the other
who for us men and for our salvation
came down from heaven and was incarnate
of the holy spirit and the virgin mary
and was made man
and was crucified also for us under
pontius pilate and suffered and was
buried
and the third day he rose again
according to the scriptures and ascended
into heaven and sits at the right hand
of the father
and he shall come again with glory to
judge the living and the dead whose
kingdom shall have no end
and we believe in the holy spirit the
lord and giver of life who proceeds from
the father now here in brackets i've
written philoque and
the sun
because even though the official nicene
constantinopolitan creed just says who
proceeds from the father as we will see
later on
as the church starts to become more and
more divided in the west in latin the
term foloque gets added which means and
the sun and once again this is starting
to address this notion of how does the
sun relate to the father so when you add
phaloque you're saying hey the holy
spirit is emanating from both the father
and the son versus just the father but
we'll get into that this was not a
matter of debate in the fourth century
but it will become a matter of debate as
we go into the 6th century and beyond
and we believe in the holy spirit the
lord and giver of life who proceeds from
the father who with the father and the
son together is worshipped and glorified
who spoke by the prophets and we believe
in one holy catholic meaning universal
and apostolic church we acknowledge one
baptism for the remission of sins we
look for the resurrection of the dead
and the life of the age to come
amen
so this is
interesting because it's you can view it
as a unification of christendom now as
we will see that
unification does not hold well over the
next several hundred years even though
arius is exiled and he dies shortly
thereafter
you continue to have sympathetic bishops
and even roman emperors to the aryan
doctrine
you also this debate between the
relation of the father and the son
continues we'll talk about this philoque
debate but maybe most important and the
biggest cause of the eventual divisions
between the church ones that carry on
even to today it's really about a power
struggle
so as we've been talking about the late
roman empire and even the fall of the
western empire in the beginning of the
byzantine empire you might already
notice that there are several very
powerful actors here with the fall of
the western roman empire you have the
byzantine emperor
who considers him and as we'll see also
herself
the roman emperor
we have the bishop the patriarch or
often known the pope of rome now rome is
significant because according to
tradition the church at rome was founded
by the apostle peter who is considered
by many to be the first amongst the
apostles but of course rome was the the
seat of the roman empire for a very very
very long time and so you could imagine
the bishop of the church of rome the
pope of rome would be a very powerful
figure
now you also have the bishop or the
patriarch of constantinople which is
another capital and really the capital
of the byzantine empire and so what
we're going to see over the next several
hundred years is a jockeying four
position amongst these three in
particular the byzantine emperor and the
pope of rome the pope of rome starts to
consider themselves as really the leader
of all of christendom the patriarch of
constantinople and the bishops of the
other major
centers of christianity like antioch and
jerusalem and alexandria they view
themselves as all kind of a college of
us peers and they will give extra
space for the pope of rome or the bishop
of rome because of that the importance
of that city and the significance of how
the church of rome was founded and this
gets this
jockeying for power over the next
several hundred years gets even more
complex as the west what was the western
roman empire or some of the areas of the
western roman empire start to get
consolidated under
germanic rule really frankish rule and
you start having this notion of a holy
roman emperor that we'll talk about in a
few hundred years down our tie blind so
keep a lookout for this power struggle
we're going to talk about particular
issues of theological doctrine things
like the philoque issue things like the
relationship between the father and the
son whether you should have icons but at
the end of the day what's eventually
going to lead to the great schism
in the beginning of the second
millennium is this power struggle